It is.
Hey, how you doing?
Hey.
Doing pretty good. How about you? Good to see you after, I think, a long time.
I'm sorry.
I said it's been a long time. I think in 2026 is the first call that we made, right?
Yeah, I think so. Yeah, the Fridays are always tough because this is a, it's a work from home day for me, so.
The.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, it's just a little, little tough to swing this day.
Right.
So, do you may prefer any other time then, from Friday to any other day?
Honestly, like Monday afternoons, I'm normally pretty flexible. And if we were meeting like once a month on a Monday afternoon, I should probably be able to accommodate that.
And what time would you prefer?
Uh...
Maybe 2?
Eastern Standard.
I'm sorry, what time is he open the entire 2P.m.?
Two P 2:00 PM ES2PM EST.
OK, let me change this to.
Two.
You want it Monday? Yeah, Monday look pretty good for Friday is always busy because everything is keep forwarding on Friday then, yeah, so I'll be starting it from anything I checked with Tanmoy, you are still not in the office, I think you're...
Yeah.
When outside driving.
Yes, I am.
Oh, okay. So what we can do for this today's call, we can reschedule this upcoming Monday and of course all the upcoming call will be on Monday too, if that works for you.
Yeah, that works for me.
Cool, sir. Yeah, thank you for this. And just a quick check, I think I would get a chance to check with you, but I hope everything is going good on Tanya side.
Yes, it is going. Everything is going well. No complaints. He's exceptional.
Thank you. Thank you for the kind work. Yeah, we'll talk a little bit deep on Monday, right? And I'll send the new invite for updating one for all the upcoming calls.
Right.
All right, sounds good. Have a great day. Bye-bye.
Yeah, thank you. Take care.